bonsoir et voir ils sont merci d'être
avec nous un mois de législatives donc
on le voit la course à sa succession
d'angela merkel est lancé les trois
candidats qui ont débattu hier on
rappelle les derniers sondages qui
donnaient un avantage clair au spd de la
fashion's clairement le débat d'hier at
il confirmé cette tendance
alors si vous permettez je vais un petit
peu rectifié ce que ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que il ya beaucoup
d'instituts de sondage et quand on fait
la moyenne on a plutôt un écart de 1 à 2
points entre le spd et la cdu ou c'est à
dire que ça reste extrêmement
serré alors bien sûr armin laschet tu ça
a été rappelé dans le reportage a
beaucoup perdu lorsqu'il a il a été
filmé par une caméra en train de rire
alors que le président de la république
fédérale d'allemagne par led et des
inondations malgré tout
comme ça a été dit aussi tout à l'heure
les parties
vont faire l'élection c'est à dire c'est
la popularité respectifs des parties
encore plus que celle des personnalités
qui aspire à être chancelier et dans ce
cadre là en fait la cd ou un léger
avantage sur le spd donc est-ce que le
facteur personnel olaf scholz tête de
liste du spd qui semble mieux passé va
l'emporter ou bien est ce que ce sera là
la faiblesse relative du spd par rapport
à la cd ou en tout cas bien malin ce
soir qui peut dire lequel des deux
parties va arriver en tête puisque on
peut exclure que le que les verts
arrivent en tête ils arriveront
peut-être en deuxième position mais
certainement pas vu les les faibles
performances de l'alena berlocq au
printemps dernier une chose est sûre
c'est que il ya une saison d'un gala
merkel plutôt très populaire très
respecté et compris l international et
là on a un chrétien-démocrate son
successeur armin laschet ti est loin
d'être aussi populaire pourquoi n'arrive
t il pas à bénéficier de cette
popularité dont bénéficiait la
chancelière
alors là encore il faut regain il faut
mettre en perspective
angela merkel très populaire moi je
mettrais un bémol
elle a fait un très mauvais score aux
élections de 2017 puisqu'elle a elle a
fait baisser son parti à 30 2 33% alors
qu'il est qu'il était jusque-là 41% et
ella ella rattraper partiellement sa
chute de popularité mais les allemands
si vous voulez son centre est
schizophrène concernant mais la merkel
parce que d'un côté il semble lui lui
prêter un certain nombre de vertus
surtout depuis qu'elle a annoncé qu'elle
ne se représentait pas et de l'autre ils
critiquent à peu près tout ce qui a été
la politique d'angela merkel que ça soit
si je fais exception des verts que ce
soit la sortie radicale de l'industrie
nucléaire que ce soit la politique
d'immigration
que ce soit la politique du coc vide
aussi parce que c'est quelque chose dont
on ne parle pas du tout mais le
mécontentement d'une partie de la
population allemande exactement comme en
france vis-à-vis d'une d'une politique
jugée trop peu en ferme east on va dire
va peser sur le sur le scrutin de du 26
septembre prochain alors un autre cas
celui de l'écologiste anna lena barbeuk
un qui était plutôt grande favorite ou
d'aller peut-être me dire qu'il faut
mettre en perspective
elle était favorite euro au printemps
mais aujourd'hui en troisième position
comment comment comprendre
sceptre régression entre guillemets
alors n'allez navires bloqués étaient
très populaires
et puis il ya eu un certain nombre de
mauvais enchaînement pour elle d'abord
des des gaffes elle n'a pas réussi à
maîtriser le discours qu'elle a fait
lors du congrès de son parti elle butait
toutes les trois phrases et d'autre part
elle a été accusée de plagiat pour le
dernier livre qu'elle a publiés alors
vous savez c'est une campagne électorale
donc ça ne ça ne vole pas très haut il
n'empêche que elle était en position de
favorite et puis elle est là et la chute
et armin laschet s'il lui arrive la même
chose est ce que en la chose a encore le
temps d'être dézinguer disent ils d'ici
l'élection du 26 septembre
peut-être peut-être pas nul ne peut dire
la seule chose qui est certaine c'est
que vous voyez avec trois parties autour
de 20% on est très loin de ce qu'était
la démocratie allemande au début de
l'ère merkel ou les deux grands partis
de tête avait 35 38 % et et frisait les
40 donc on peut dire que là le prochain
gouvernement allemand sera forcément à
trois parties et il aura beaucoup de mal
décider rapidement ça va être un
changement complet et en particulier
pour nous autres français nous avons
l'habitude de nous tourner vers berlin
pour savoir ce qui a décidé à berlin
mais là à berlin on va décider des
compromis un peu laborieux et on va les
décidé très lentement ça va avoir des
répercussions sur l'europe à suivre donc
merci edouard husson d'avoir été avec
mon nous avoir apporté va trois analyses